[Music]
kunal they are celebrating the Emmys
with Audi Thursday night in LA and
spilling on the new season of it the Big
Bang Theory with ET all right exciting
weekend but I also have an exciting
season premiere coming up soon everyone
wants to know what what does Amy stay to
Sheldon
I can't tell you but I'll tell you
so far we've we've shot almost four
episodes for enough episodes were in the
middle of it and I can't tell you how
good the writing is this season you know
Season eleven it just keeps getting
stronger and stronger and we feel so
lucky to be to be back and to be
stronger than ever
when you read the season premiere and
you found out what Amy says what was
your reaction very you are a ace at this
I think that I thought that the season
the the season finale last season was
some of the best 22 minutes of
television I've ever witnessed then when
I read this one and I then we shot it
this is in my opinion some of the best
22 minutes of television we beat our old
finale season 10 finale by a lot in my
opinion there will be an answer one way
or the other though Amy won't give an
answer they will be an answer this
season one way or the other I'll take
that ah Raj is now a little behind the
group in terms of personal life what do
you think's gonna happen with Raj this
season you know the fun is being the
consummate bachelor because I get to
really explore that side of his
character I think if he was to just find
love not that it would be easy but if
you were to find love then I wouldn't
get to explore the many nuances of his
character so I'm enjoying sort of his
singlehood living vicariously through
Raj though that's probably not the best
person we have I carry through but it's
no it's it's I don't know I don't think
I think he's gonna try and he's not
gonna continue to struggle
[Music]